pj joyce will make the start there was a
possibility it was going to be matt
shoemaker but the blue jays will send
zwick to the mound this will be his
third
appearance of the season his first start
and we'll talk about this more in the
second inning we'll just
now that nevin ashley that is not the
play you're looking for down the line
right there but
boy there's a lot look at evan's over
two times
where's your glove get your bit off
there yeah yeah
the 2-2 and another hard hit ball he's
gonna get another chance
he's got to make it finally
he got his catcher's mid but he didn't
come up with it cleanly yeah but he kept
him in front of him wow
this is a big leap pop-up right here
and it'll be panicked to make the catch
and the side is retired
in the top of the first nice start for
zoyd take a look at john mayne's numbers
on the year this will be his tenth start
a couple wins 502 earned run average has
really come down
a lot in his last three starts full
count he threw it by him for a strikeout
one down one two another breaking ball
strike three
hernandez down second strikeout for john
means
popped up could fall tough play for the
orioles and
mullins gets there at that blazing speed
lord goriel junior leads it off for the
blue jays against john means
this is not what you want to see not at
this time of the year
that foul ball he got the curveball it
looked like he hit it right on top of
his foot
and managers cringe anytime you see the
possibility of a
player getting injured but especially
now here we are the final saturday of
the season
and their strike three blew it by them
for the third strikeout for john means
two pitch on the way and yep he gets to
take a seat
oh iglesias with the spin and the toss
and he got him
blue jays down in the second inning
couple of k's for john means
so zoey not giving up hard contact but
there are a couple of men on with only
one out for the dangerous jose iglesias
where's the play going to be here vicio
back to first and they don't get him
guerrero off the bag vlady immediately
signaling into the dugout to have a look
at it i think vlady's foot came off the
back
i think when he stretched it pulled him
away from the first base bag and the
first base empire had a good look at it
another look right here and he's off the
base oh
wow the blue jays challenged and very
quickly they overturn it and call him
out let's see if he can get out of this
and a ground ball to second it looks
like he will vr onto first nicely done
tj zoid he's got 10 outs eight of them
are on the ground
so you could see them this can be tricky
vladi going down the line
got it nice little over the shoulder
catch by guerrero
boy the more repetitions that ronnie
gets at first place the better he's
getting
davis is there and makes the catch and
it's another scoreless inning for t.j
zoie
two and two two down nobody on john
means has not given up a hit so far
and it's a called strike three he
painted the black at the knees
and means strikes out guerrero jr here's
jose iglesias
3-2 ground ball to third
biggio's got it and iglesias and the
orioles are retired
five scoreless innings for tj zoig john
means has been superb so far tonight
two balls two strikes got him strikeout
number six guriel's down
he gets it and goes here he comes and he
got him
that's three straight strikeouts for
john means he's getting into that rhythm
now
seven of the game near a curveball
swinging a miss over a pitch in the dirt
john means strikes out this sign in the
bottom of the fifth
16-row retired by the lefty kevin biz
shows the batter
now bitchio gets a hold of one deep
right field
it's gone and the first hit of the night
for the blue jays gives them a one to
nothing lead
breaks up the no-hitter in dramatic
fashion no way
said john means though gavin who was
over three
against john means before hitting that
home run
now the first at-bat for randall grichik
who took over for guriel gangurya
leaving with a
contusion on his left foot after a foul
ball and randall sends one down the
right field line this has possibilities
and it's gone just inside the pole for a
three run homer
a terrific season for randall and he's
swinging it back
well at the end of the year
that's hit well deep center field gritch
rakisson back and it's off the top of
the wall floating into second hayes
coming hard around third
and he will score so an rbi double
iglesia's second double of the game we
talked about
he's a doubles machine that's number 17
on the year for him
down the right field line he's hit it
pretty well
and it's off the wall de oscar comes up
with it in a hurry throw to second
got him boy what a throw by tay oscar
hernandez
a run comes in to make it four to two
but hernandez with a perfect throw to
second base
what a throw by t oscar so now vladimir
guerrero jr
chopper back to the mound scott's coming
home and the ball is dropped
bisho will score and it's five to two
blue chase and out away from beating
baltimore again
and there's strike three paul durende
great job by bass
and another victory for the blue chase